thank you
[Music]
glad to be with you this week or I guess
post week the Fourth of July where a
little less news of the day and we can
sit down with with experts people who
really know their field well and are
making a big difference and we were
introduced actually by a good friend of
mine uh doc Jordan Peterson you can
follow him on Twitter at Bjorn lombborg
I'll have that uh bottom lower third
because to white Americans It's probably
hard to spell he has a book out here
best things first the 12 most efficient
solutions to the world's poorest and our
Global sdg promises this is a man who
discusses climate change quite a bit has
studied it and I would say it takes a
pretty reasonable approach rational
approach will agree on some disagree on
others regarding Solutions going forward
Mr lumborg thanks for being here sir
it's great to be here Stephen I'm I'm uh
well look at my let's not lay it on too
thick from the outset it's okay uh so
now
let me call you Stephen though
that's true thank you yeah I was telling
him before uh we started uh filming here
that my mother named me Steven because
she she was okay with the nickname Steve
it was the only nickname and then she
decided that she hated the nickname
Steve and that actually it relates to
you you know you do have a problem it's
a good problem you've become so good at
English that your accent is almost
non-discernable my mom has that as a
French Canadian but then maybe sometimes
expressions or tenses might be and
people go wait what's what's going on
here is he dyslexic he's like no no he's
Danish
yes that's my excuse yeah you don't have
a very you don't have an accent that's
really identifiable but you speak four
languages right
I have a yes or
coming up on five oh yeah okay all right
I'm sorry I didn't mean to spoil your
day like that but that is very
impressive uh and my mom will get it all
the time her accent's just subtle enough
but you know it's still a second
language I would not do very well in
Danish so um I appreciate it that's why
we're talking English yes thank you very
much you're not even meeting me in the
middle you're coming the whole way here
so I appreciate that
um now you are the president of the
Copenhagen uh Copenhagen consensus
center it's a think tank and you've been
named one of the 100 most influential
people in the world by Time magazine for
people who who aren't necessarily
familiar and I think most people are
explain to them what it is that you do
and how your approach is different in
the world of uh climate change and
specifically climate change sort of
alarmism that we're seeing out there now
oh that's a very good question so
fundamentally I try to say not just what
does the science tell us because you
know there's been a lot of discussion in
the science but what should we do about
that and what I try to say is we don't
have infinite money we don't have
resources to just throw out everything
we really need to ask ourselves where
can we do the most good so my
conversation on climate change and all
the other things that we'll talk about
later is not is it a problem or not of
course global warming is real it's a
problem it's man-made it is something
that we should be concerned about but
first of all we need to get it right on
the level of concern and a lot of people
think this is the end of the world it's
by no means the end of the world and we
can get into that and then secondly how
do you fix it well a lot of people seem
to suggest we need to do everything and
the kitchen sink to fix this problem
which basically means we're going to
have very little money left for all the
other problems in the world that's not
only wrong because we end up spending a
lot of money really poorly but also
because we forget all the other
challenges that the world is facing so
I'm really trying to take a step back
from this whole conversation it's not
about is it right or wrong but it's much
more the policies that we then make for
climate change and all the other
problems are they smart and
unfortunately often they're not well I
think and right off the bat you'll have
some people who disagree including some
scientists regarding
um you know that you have to accept
certain premises right okay is the earth
warming uh are humans the cause of it
and then you get to by how much will
that have catastrophic events and then
for policy at the ones that we're
certainly discussing that our proposed
or have been signed can international
governing bodies fix it but you do
accept that the Earth is warming you
believe that humans are the primary
cause of it and what's the data that you
rely on uh for that before people say
you're paid by a big oil right that'll
be
had to address it
I'm simply taking my starting point in
the U.N climate panel reports uh I I
think most people probably never read
them you shouldn't it's a 4 000 pages of
really really boring a little late for
that I've done it and I wanted to blow
my head off but I appreciate the the
spirit of the morning the too late
warning yes uh but you know if you
actually read what they say and I think
it's reasonable to say they're they're
as
closest we get to a gold standard of
what global warming is they tell us
global warming is a problem there's
nothing in there that tells us this is
the end of the world so again I'm not a
natural scientist I'm a social scientist
I'm a economy Economist actually I'm a
little bit of a pretend Economist I'm a
political scientist uh but you know
pretty much all economists so it's okay
I won't hold it against you yeah so
thank you uh so I try to talk about what
is the cost what's the benefit of
different solutions but I simply take a
starting point lots of really smart
people have been looking at this there
is a problem not the end of the world
how do we fix it right well and the
reason I do bring that up and again I
appreciate your rational approaches
because if you look at these same
reports right there's a consistent theme
if you look at the proposals coming from
places like the U.N and uh some of them
you do address obviously will talk about
sort of what their focus is as far as
green energy or Renewables but the
consistent focus seems to be okay this
entirely uh I guess it's a tectonic
shift in all of the ways that we consume
energy and depopulation right I was
there at the U.N climate Summit where I
watched Ted Turner proposed China's one
child policy to thunderous Applause and
it surprised me as a young
20-something-year-old so I think that
yeah I know we want to reach across the
aisles but we do need to remember there
are people on that side of the eye going
wait a second if it's the gold standard
but it's also married with these
policies that are viewed as pretty
radical and anti-freedom that is an
important balance for not just the the
economic measures but you know the
freedom that people value versus uh
control because I think that's at stake
in a lot of these proposed policies and
I think a little bit is also because the
U.N is very bad at sort of keeping the
different conversations apart the U.N
climate panel is is actually trying to
do real and good and scientific work
then there is sort of a overlay on who
gets to summarize this for policy makers
which is obviously something governments
does uh they they certainly sharpen they
often slightly manipulate some of the uh
conclusions and then of course they get
much sensationalized when they get into
the media and then you have all the
people like Ted Turner and everybody
else who shows up at these negotiations
which actually hosted by a different
organization the UNF Triple C and they
are very very much for saying we need to
you know gung-ho go all the way on
Renewables and we need to you know
depopulation and deep growth and all
kinds of other things look these are
things that people throw up they don't
all mean all of it but you know
fundamentally there's a lot of things in
there that are both very ineffective
very unlikely to happen and simply not
the way that you're going to get most
people on board to actually fix anything
like climate change right and let me get
to I think obviously if people let's say
start off with with different points
okay let's all uh go with climate change
is happening humans are a I should say a
cause of it if we don't necessarily go
with the sole or primary cause okay that
brings us to the idea of you know it
having cataclysmic results uh in your
lecture and I watched watched all that
Purdue um I think it was Purdue was
within the last six months something
stood out at me
you said that we don't have good strong
data for climate change increasing
climate-related deaths uh so could you I
guess sort of fill me in on what that
means and what data there would be the
most convincing compelling or people
should focus on if it's incomplete
yes so
first of all if you look at how
people die from climate related
disasters that be storms wildfires uh
droughts and floods those are sort of
the best ones that we have good evidence
for at least for the last uh Century or
so uh it's not such I think most people
if you just ask them they would probably
assume oh it's going up and up I mean
certainly that's what I'm seeing on CNN
and all kinds of you know news reports
all the time actually it's gone down
dramatically uh so it used to be that
these four uh things of floodstroms
droughts and uh and uh Wildfire killed
about half a million people each year on
the planet uh the last decade it was
down to below 20 000 people so we've
seen a reduction of what 97 of
thereabouts and remember this is at the
same time as the world has poor Drupal
in size so we've simply been become much
much safer now this is not really
anything to do with climate it has to do
with the fact that if you're richer
you're more zillion you know if you're
poor you're really vulnerable if you're
not poor you're much less vulnerable so
this is basically a fact of us getting
out of vulnerability and that's of
course crucial because that's really
what's going to fix a lot of the
problems that we'll get from global
warming not actually fixing global
warming first but making sure that
people are no longer vulnerable uh the
second one the second indicator that you
could look at is heat and cold deaths so
a lot of people are enough to say uh you
know as temperatures rise you're going
to see more heat waves
absolutely true
gonna make is that going to make it more
dangerous well there's two things to it
first of all you need to recognize that
by all measures this is a very large
International well-established uh result
from across the literature but perhaps
the best one is from 2021 the landsat
journal they estimate that globally
about half a million people die from
heat every year so from two hot
temperatures but about 4.5 million
people die from two cold temperatures so
nine times as many we're not talking
about a world where most people die from
heat no most people die from cold cold
is fantastically more dangerous for a
lot of different reasons and again if
you look at what's happened with the
change in temperature it's not such that
as temperatures go up you just see more
people die from heat although you
probably do that you also see fewer
people dying from colon because many
more people die from cold over the last
20 years as temperatures risen we've
actually seen it decline and then the
total number of people dying from cold
and heat because more people die from
heat but many fewer people are dying
well I'd like to you every year jump in
there because we did speak about this
not too long ago some numbers that were
so unbelievable that I had to triple
check them here at my own show we make
all of the references publicly available
into people watching right now you can
follow along with sort of the
bibliography um and I was raised in
Montreal you know it was the first
agreement right was Montreal before was
Kyoto before it was Paris uh and now I
live in Texas and so people will now
discuss this heat wave in Texas but I
lived through the ice storm in Montreal
where I did have actual you know people
I knew die and this brings me to the
point that yes there are vastly more
deaths from cold than heat and part of
that reason right is we're more
technologically equipped in many ways to
deal with what we would see is certainly
the extreme heat these heat waves then
for example ice storms which occur with
great regularity a stat that shocked me
was if you look at the average yearly
heat deaths in the United States it's
about 702. now in Europe it's about 15
000. this was according to the the CDC
and who but the U.S 90 of Americans have
air conditioning and only 10 percent in
Europe and if you look at the green
policies they obviously are proposing
reducing or outright eliminating air
conditioning which could lead to
countless more deaths with heat and
that's that's my ultimate concern is
these policies being anti-people
oh absolutely and again uh you have to
be very careful when you talk about
people dying from heat that's typically
just the very very extreme end of the
scale it's acute ice storms is also the
extreme uh other end most people
actually die of just you know
uncomfortable extra heat or
uncomfortable extra cold uh because what
happens is when you have heat uh it it
gets harder to you know uh vigorously
exercise it gets harder to do a lot of
things and especially older people will
have more of risk to die if you are more
cold you will have higher blood pressure
and that leads to cardiac arrest and
many other problems so this is sort of
secondary effect but you're absolutely
right many more people die from not
being able to keep cold when it's hot or
keep warm when it's cold how do you do
that with the electricity you do that
with access to cheap energy right and so
when we make energy more expensive we
actually make people die more there's a
great study a couple of years ago that
showed what happened when the U.S did
fracking uh fracking had a lot of
different impacts one of them was the
gas which Heats about 70 of all
Americans homes became much cheaper that
means especially poor people could keep
their homes better heated in the winter
what is the impact of that well the
researchers estimated that that by
itself meant that each year 11
000 fewer Americans died every year and
of course conversely if you now make
energy more expensive again what happens
eleven thousand more people will die
each and every year this is not Costless
and again it's not just because people
like to sort of suggest oh it's just
because you love money that you're so
concerned about the fact that that cost
will go up with climate policies well
money is just a shorthand
all the things that people can do yes it
means you can go more on vacation but
also means you can actually keep your
house heated so you don't die in Winter
also by the way that's the Crux that's a
very rich white guy thing to say that
you just care about money go tell that
to some kid living in rural India who
can't who can't actually keep himself
cool to any degree or in some cases make
sure that his food is safe to eat
because he doesn't have the ability to
cook it it's such a privileged point of
view and they try and throw it out
and and again uh people then think oh
maybe it's true if you're from Canada or
uh I'm from uh from from Denmark maybe
they just think cold is a really big
thing but actually even in India one of
the hottest places on planet we estimate
cool deaths so deaths that are below the
optimal temperature are much much worse
so the estimates again is uh that about
60 000 people in India will die from
heat but more than 600 000 people will
die from coal and so again these kids
need to be insured that they don't die
especially when it's much colder
sometimes just a couple of months uh
through the year when it's much colder
why aren't we talking about that and why
are we so focused on making sure that
energy becomes more expensive especially
for the poor no I think it's a very
important point I mean if you take it
all into account let's even reduce it
right from Air Conditioning or
centralized air hey if it gets that cold
how many of them have parkas what's
required to create a parka what do you
think you know the zippers are made of
what what likely some kind of petroleum
product unless you're you know unless
you're like Andrew Tate and it's
probably made of solid gold but the
point remains let me ask you um let me
ask you this because you made some
really good points on this and uh I
can't remember the data reference that
you used was it like something i e a c I
know uh this was in relation to
separating sometimes just carbon dioxide
or carbon emissions versus pollution
because this is something uh that is
surprising a lot of people so many
people today Global burden of disease
yes oh that's right of disease yes they
they look at what do people die from in
all kinds of different ways and you know
you just gotta shake your head in
disbelief when people say uh you know
climate change is the most important
issue in in global health or even for
American Health no it's not you know by
far and look people know this by far the
most important thing is that you die
from uh uh uh cardiovascular disease and
cancer uh but also that you die from
cold rather than he but in the poor part
of the world and we often forget that
now environmental issues are big but
it's not what you think it's not climate
change it's air pollution in rich
countries it's outdoor air pollution
that's dangerous but in most of the poor
world
one of the most important issues is
indoor air pollution is the fact that
most people in the developing World cook
can keep warm with dirty fuels like dung
cardboard wood whatever they can lay
their hands on and and and that's why
the World Health Organization actually
estimates the average indoor air
pollution the average indoor air in most
third world hunts is about 10 times more
polluted than the worst outdoor air
pollution in Beijing or New Delhi so we
have no sense of this uh you know indoor
in most developing countries is a little
bit like smoking two packs of cigarettes
each day not surprisingly That's not
healthy for you no well I did that for
about uh 13 years of my life growing up
in a French Canadian apartment a
three-bedroom apartment every New Year's
party that was probably a case of
cigarette packs everyone smoked but yes
um okay so and I think that's important
because
I think you gave a lot of people on
board with the idea of we need to
pollute less right versus we need to
eliminate the use of fossil fuels or
carbon emissions they're two very
different things and a lot of the
successful proposals that have taken
place even more so
proposals regarding pollution and
sometimes that also by the way brings us
to environmental impact of solar and
wind the environmental impact can be
worse or larger even if so-called carbon
emissions are less they're not always
one and the same they affect people
differently but let's go with this
premise okay from these people because
you have obviously 12 kind of steps that
you think would be productive let me ask
you this let's say uh do we also believe
that the government right before we get
to your proposals and this is where you
can color me skeptical more specifically
this International sort of Coalition
that entirely relies on the United
States government
um to be clear and that's why Americans
are more apprehensive
do you believe that government itself or
all governments could actually change
the course of the earth's climate in any
way and if not what are the what are the
proposals that could actually have an
impact
not in the way that they're going about
it because fundamentally as you point
out look we're trying to make agreements
and they did that in Cancun and all the
other uh climate meetings where they're
basically trying to tell everyone we
know that you like your fossil fuels
because it basically supports jobs and
economy and you know it gives you heat
in the winter and cool in the summer and
all these other great things that you
like but could you stop using that would
that be okay for you right uh and not
surprisingly nobody actually wants to
say that but everybody goes there they
sort of say sure I'll do that in 10 or
15 years or something when somebody else
is in power and then Nobody Does it
that's not surprisingly not a terribly
good way to do it now you have some
people and increasingly so in much of
the rich world that are actually going
to try to do something along those lines
so you know Biden in the U.S and much of
the Europe uh uh Justin Trudeau in
Canada many other places where they're
actually saying look we're going to
spend a lot of money to try to at least
rip a little little bit of this engine
of growth out from our economy again
this is going to be fairly costly it's
not going to cut very much and we've
seen how hard it is to actually do this
and of course once the price starts
increasing most people will say screw
that you know I'm going to vote that guy
out right so this is an unsustainable
and unrealistic way mostly to try to fix
the problem which is why it's failing
and which is why I'm trying to say
there's this much much smarter way to do
this fundamentally look at what the US
did again back with fracking fracking
was basically this idea that we can get
to a lot of gas in the US that we
couldn't before with a new technology so
the US DARPA basically and and sorry
DARPA and uh the uh uh Department of
energy spent a lot of money on funding
guys who thought we can do this but it's
not commercially viable right now they
spent probably about 10 billion dollars
in total it turned out to be a fantastic
for the US right it makes you because it
made much cheaper uh energy available
you probably got rich to the tune of
about 180 billion dollars every year at
least for a decade or so this has been a
great idea there are also costs uh the
the Total Environmental cost is probably
in the order of 20 25 billion dollars so
it's not nothing but much much smaller
than the benefit and here's the kicker
it turns out that gas emits much less
CO2 than coal and when you make gas
cheaper on people stop using coal and
start using gas instead and so the U
.s carbon emissions much more than any
other Nation over the last decade decade
and a half so both through Obama Trump
and Biden not primarily because you were
green but because this innovation made
it cheaper to switch to frac gas right
this tells you the very simple point if
you can make Greener technology cheaper
than fossil fuels people will switch
that's what we need until the government
steps in and says no that's a big
problem right with American policy do
you have an Administration by
Administration who paused a lot of
fracking leases or any new developments
and that that kind of brings us to
obviously he's doing this in line with
the un uh in line with a lot of these
guidelines uh because gas bat right and
I think it's very important you just
brought up hold on a second you need to
do a risk uh you know a cost-benefit
analysis it's better than other forms of
energy doesn't matter politically
they've said gas bad and uh now fracking
is is not nearly um it's not growing
nearly as quickly and may come to a
point of proposals make it through where
it may not be allowed at all or we have
to phase it out uh so that brings in
okay if we're talking about governments
these proposals and your proposals by
the way are so reasonable compared to
the the SBG like this thing is a wish
list for children like end poverty great
so I appreciate yours but who are the
adults in the room right if we have for
example Donald Trump saying well on this
Paris this Paris agreement isn't going
to do what we needed to do and Brian's
saying no we're going to sign on and
also I'm going to end fracking because I
know for someone from Denmark it would
be very hard to give any credit to
someone like a trump as it relates to
fracking and saying maybe the policy of
ending for acting isn't quite uh
reasonable but that's what we're doing
yes yeah look so so fundamentally I
think it's going to be hard to really
stop the fracking Revolution because
it's actually powered so much of the US
uh both economy and also if you stop
fracking you're actually going to go
back and emit a lot more CO2 right what
we do need is to get China and India to
Frack so that they can also cut their
carbon emissions oh and become rich at
the same time so there's a huge
opportunity there but my point here is
to say we need to make sure that policy
makers support a lot more of that kind
of innovation fairly cheap Innovation
that drives much much better technology
but then everyone will want to buy
and actually it turns out that I think
most politicians would also like to do
that but it's just not this this is not
the conversation that we have on the
sidelines of the Paris agreement we
actually had most leaders most of the
leaders that you normally hear about
with climate uh together with Bill Gates
and a lot of the other Rich billionaires
coming together and saying we should uh
spend a lot more on innovation in this
world because Innovation is what makes
us rich and is what solves most problems
uh and you know look unlike the climate
agreements that are literally going to
cost trillions of dollars each year this
costs you know in the tens of billions
of dollars so it's you know like a
hundred times cheaper right this is the
kind of stuff we need to do I'm I'm
afraid I can't really sort of point out
there's certainly no leaders I'm not
sure we've tried also to get to Trump to
say Innovation sure he would he he loves
to say no to stuff I'm not so sure that
he was all that great at saying yes to
something else well certainly as it
relates to certainly as it relates to
energy compared to Biden right find me a
single American Democrat who is going to
say yes we need to allow India to frack
we need more politicians who are
actually going to say instead of you
know just saying no to a lot of stuff
which will never work in the long run we
need to find politicians who'll say
Innovation is the way forward well and I
think you know this is the one area with
I agree with your direction I don't have
the trust in government so for example
this Innovation often does come from the
Privacy rather than spending any money
you know not taking money from the
people innovating I mean for example
horses aren't extinct people moved on to
the Model T because Henry Ford gave it
to us right and people wanted to have a
Ford uh you know people can still use
salt to preserve food if they want to
smoke the meat and stuff but they prefer
Refrigeration they weren't outlawed they
weren't banned you didn't need to
subsidize it what about an approach of
especially considering how charitable
American people and businesses are
um just not taking so much of their
money otherwise we're trusting these
governments to spend these billions
where we want it to go even if the
solution is a correct one
I I hear you point and I think there's
certainly some value to it let me let me
just give you a sort of Economist
argument for why there might be an
argument for for governments to be
spending this remember again fracking
was made possible because government was
willing to Pony up a little bit of money
to try this out in 20 years to get it
right and then fracking just ran on its
own uh you know the iPhone and there's
been many of these other examples a lot
of the things that went into it the you
know World Wide Web uh were first done
by government so there is an argument to
sort of spend a little bit of seed money
uh and if you if you look at for
instance a lot of other research uh into
diseases uh we have government spend a
lot of money on if you will blue sky
research the kind of stuff that delivers
no Bells but then eventually we hope
that that goes into stuff they'll become
a medication that you can get a private
company to make and sell and get
everyone to buy so the point is there's
a good argument to make the research
that is long-term and that's hard for
individuals to recoup their investments
from uh the main problem is if you spend
money you come up with a great idea but
the idea will only break through in 20
or 30 years your patents run out and
that's why we need to make sure that we
have these universities and researchers
and you know uh Eggheads uh delivering
all those things that will eventually
make us rich in 20 30 40 years I would
and not to be adversarial but I would
disagree with the premise just using
those examples okay and this is
something of you know worked kind of
study this for a while I know I'm a
comedian but you know I was there at the
Cancun climate Summit and I've been
covering this for a long time it's
called John Stossel and I I met uh you
talk about fracking now fracking wasn't
made possible because government funded
it fracking was made possible sure it
coincided with the government not being
being punitively prohibitive the
internet is another example you
mentioned the internet it was basically
used as glorified intercom right to sort
of militarily only once was opened up to
private innovators that become the
internet that we knew today drug
research we talk about well there's no
country in the history of the world
that's provided new medical Innovation
outside of the United States and the
vast majority of that has come from the
private sector that's why when Canada
went public their medical research
actually just plummeted to an
unparalleled degree so I think sometimes
there's the the chicken or the egg and
people think it's because of government
no it's hold on a second there were
points in time where the government
Reigns and the shackles were removed and
the private sector was able to innovate
I think it needs a little of both
but I don't want to give too much credit
to government yeah I I just want to
mention one thing Mitchell who was
probably the single biggest guy in in
sort of getting the fracking uh through
uh he he's on record for saying very
much it would never have had without the
uh the support of the doe for you know a
decade or more I'm not taking money
no no no but but but but it sort of
suggests that you know it's hard to
actually he had a hard time for instance
convincing his investors keep doing this
and that was why doe was uh was
necessary my point here is simply to say
that we should spend much less money but
more smartly in Innovation and there's a
lot of good examples uh uh on on how
innovation has been helped along with
good investments from governments just
simply because the time frame is too
long for private interest I'd be able to
recoup the full uh benefit and I agree
with that and I think I think if we're
going to be making Investments at all
that it should be made in areas that
have a proven track record you know as
opposed to every Green investment quote
unquote green has been a disaster right
things like solyndra if you look at the
subsidizing of solar and wind which
you've discussed quite a bit
um let me actually ask you this because
this ties into your proposals right as
far as and I'd like to know what they
are specifically but a lot most people
out there will hear Renewables
Renewables in their head that's wind and
solar right
um and nuclear isn't even something
that's necessarily brought into the
table and I know you have certain
opinions on that and we agree on on a
lot of it but when in solar what
percentage of the Earth's energy right
now this planet's energy comes from wind
and solar and if the people who their
climate to change alarmists would have
their way unfettered how much would it
rise I think it's startling to most
people so right now it's less than two
percent of all Global energy so people
tend to focus just on electricity but
remember the vast amount of energy that
we use is not electricity uh that's the
heating that's the cooling that's the
transportation is industrial processes
it's cement uh fertilizer all these
other things uh and so it's delivering
very very little and most of it is only
delivered because we subsidize it quite
heavily uh and and what most people seem
to be suggesting is oh we should go to
you know near a hundred percent with
this that's just not plausible because
what are you going to do when the sun is
not shining and the wind is not blowing
uh you actually need an enormous map of
backup we're not talking about a little
bit of batteries right right now the
world has batteries enough to keep us
powered on uh when the Sun dies down
sorry the sun stops and the wind dies
down for about a minute it and 15
seconds
by the end of this decade we might even
be up to 11 minutes but you know nights
usually take longer than that yeah it's
just something this is just not
realistic in any you know sort of
reasonable time frame and of course
remember if you actually want to buy all
those extra batteries you also need to
buy extra solar panels and wind turbine
to fill them up you've just made energy
three times more expensive because you
needed to buy the wind turbines for now
the wind turbines for later and the
batteries so you know people will tell
themselves these stories oh it's all
commercially viable right now no it's
true that solar when the sun is shining
is can be very cheap but when the sun is
not shining it's infinitely costly and
we need to be honest about this if
you're gonna have a solution it'll have
to be nuclear as you point out for
electricity and nuclear is still pretty
expensive we could possibly make it a
lot cheaper uh with fourth generation
nuclear but otherwise we have to come up
with new and great Innovations but if we
if we so let me just give you one
example Craig Venter the guy who cracked
the human genome back in 2000 uh yes
it's a crazy idea and I think you know
some of definitely we're gonna you know
we're gonna eventually end up with one
crazy idea just just ended up working
right he has this idea of having uh
algae out on the ocean surface soaking
up sunlight and CO2 and creating oil
then we'll Harvest them out on the ocean
surface and we'll create oil we'll just
basically have our own Saudi arabias out
on the uh on the ocean and and of course
then we can keep our entire fossil fuel
economy because it'll be so neutral CO2
neutral it was just soaked up out in the
ocean surface a couple of months ago
right
this is
principle doable it's
it's way far from cost effective right
but maybe you know thumbing this Egghead
to come up with a better way of doing
this hey if that could work that would
be you know a fantastic outcome for for
all of humanity so again it's the point
of saying we need a thousand slightly
crazy guys like that he has a good track
record right uh but a slightly of crazy
guys they'll come up with different
ideas we fund them for a little bit and
then maybe one of them are actually
going to power the 21st century and
we'll take those uh wonderful
contributions to humanity and turn it
into something as stupid as 23 in me but
I do know that I am 0.5 sub-Saharan
African so
and that actually brings me to something
you know this this idea right and I've
heard about this before and it kind of
seemed more like fantasy the idea of
this algae that absorb CO2 okay and
create oil
but is carbon dioxide the basically you
know the neurotoxin atmospheric poison
that people make it out to me because
you just pointed out plants thrive on it
right they absorb CO2 they actually if
you look throughout right not just we're
not talking about human history but if
you look throughout all of geology that
we have that's when there are a lot of
booms of foliage and plants right the
higher the CO2 in the atmosphere so why
are we so focused on eliminating it if
hey these that's what they eat
yes so uh CO2 makes the world Greener
that's absolutely uncontroversial uh
incontrovertible uh it's one of the main
signs actually of climate change as they
like to point out but not really tell
you uh so we have like three continents
more of leaves on the planet of the last
25 years uh three continents of the US
uh extra area of leaves on plants around
the world uh so the world has just
gotten a lot Greener that's great
everyone knows you know if you have if
you grow tomatoes in a greenhouse you
pump an extra CO2 because it makes the
tomatoes bigger uh you know it's just a
great uh uh uh fertilizer uh the the
point to remember is that uh just
because you know it was really really uh
green and leafy in the Jurassic period
uh it doesn't necessarily mean that our
societies today would be well suited for
that and so the the argument really from
an economist point of view is again you
know both Boston and Miami are great at
where they they are but if it got a lot
warmer or a lot colder they would both
be misadapted and it would cost a lot of
extra money to adapt them to whatever
that temperature is so the point here is
mainly we don't want to get to Swerve
too far away from what it used to be
when we put down all our infrastructure
that's that's the main reason no and I
understand to go back to your point
about extremes right like ice storms and
heat waves I'm talking about more more
so moderate for example the the
catastrophic sort of projections are
about uh two point is a 2.4 degrees
Celsius is the increase over a period of
100 over around two two to two point
five right okay I know there are
different numbers so for talking about
that does that have the kind of
catastrophic results and is there again
somewhat do we have to take into account
for example the reward portion of that
equation as far as like the Great
Barrier Reef right whenever very rare
that we hear that it's actually there's
areas of more Coral that in the last 30
years yes we should absolutely remember
they're both benefits and this benefits
from climate change and you know there
are more disbenefits and benefits that's
why it's a problem but not talking about
the benefits at all is also a very very
dangerous way of trying to think about
it so you know this is what climate
economists have done for a very long
time uh so they're literally thousands
of climate economists around the world
uh only one of them has ever gotten the
Nobel Prize in climate economics is
called William norhouse from Yale
University in 2018 his estimate a lot of
other climate economists is if we do
nothing about climate by the end of the
century it's going to feel like we're
about four percent less well-off than we
are than we'll actually be Remember by
then we'll be much much better off so
what you have to remember is I think if
I'm not mistaken to jump in we'll be
I've heard low estimates at 300
something percent wealthier and as high
as 450 wealthier in that same time frame
I have that about right yes so the UN
estimate will be 450 as Rich by the end
of the century as we are today this is
on sort of the standard scenario we'll
be much much better off just like we are
much better off today than we were in
1923 right right so the point here is
it'll be a much much better world but
because of global warming it'll feel
like we're not 450 it's rich but only
434 percent as Rich yes that's a problem
no it's not it's not the end of the
world to me that's not a problem
no I'd say I'd take the four I'd take a
434 pay raise tomorrow uh only I pay
myself oh that's very generous of you
I'm sorry I'm
and I think it's by the way important
for people to know because they're going
they're just talking about money this is
just a metric that's used right we're
not actually talking about dollars it's
estimating the reward and the risks and
the welfare that people will experience
by the end of the century so there are
going to be downsides but there's going
to be lots of upsize most of them are
going to come from technology and the
fact that when people are richer they're
less vulnerable right so again we need
to get it right so what are the most
effective assuming and I don't but
assume that these International
governments aren't corrupt
um which by the way I thought it was
funny when you pulled people right as
far as biggest problems across the globe
corruption was up there in the top three
or five and if you look at the SBG goals
to accomplish eliminating corruption is
nowhere in there
um but uh let's assume that there isn't
corruption that the money goes where
it's supposed to
what are the most effective Solutions
what would you say where do we start
thank you very much because I've written
a book about that yes exactly and make
sure to make sure I have the name of the
book in front of me again it is the best
things first the 12 most efficient
Solutions so and I do recommend people
go and read it
yes so we basically tried to say we
promise all these great things fixing
climate change is one of them we've also
promised to fix corruption as you
mentioned fix education fix Health fix
hunger effects uh poverty fix everything
else and oh and get organic apples and
Community Gardens to everyone you know
the whole shipping the world has
literally promised us that the US
government everybody else we're failing
badly and so we're saying look maybe the
right approach is not to promise
everything to everyone all the time
that's just silly let's find the
smartest things that could actually do a
huge amount of good for Fairly little
money and so I'm just going to give you
two of the examples but you know we go
through 12 different great ideas so one
is to focus on maternal and newborn
Health one thing that blew my mind is
the fact that every year about 300 000
moms die in childbirth and 2.3 million
kids die in their first month on this
planet mostly in poor countries and it's
not rocket science why they do it's
because they go they you know giving
birth is pretty dangerous and you fix it
by going to an Institutional get birth
and institutional setting and make sure
that you have sort of those safety
procedures not enormously effect uh
sorry not enormously complicated ones
but just really cheap ones so get moms
in give like alcohol like alcohol swabs
by the way and that sounds reductive to
rich white people in the United States
they don't have the ability to disinfect
anything in many countries when a woman
gives birth and I do mean that I do mean
to be reductive like disinfectant
yes it's very very simple stuff uh one
one of the things about 700 000 kids die
each year because they don't ever start
breathing
and we know how to this happens in Rich
World about five percent of all kits
that are uh that uh that are given
births uh they don't breathe from start
so you need to put a mask over them and
apply positive air pressure get the air
in the lungs and the kid go and then
survives yeah why don't we do that it
costs 65 for for a hand pump and
25 lives you know this is just one of
those many many examples so what we find
is if we spent collectively as a world
about five billion odds so this is not
nothing but yeah in the big scheme of
things not very much if you spend about
five billion dollars a year we could
save
1.4 million people 1.2 million kids and
166 000 moms and again you mentioned
that this is if everybody's uncorrupt
and stuff no no we actually included
that you know there'll be some of it
that goes to corruption there'll be a
lot of it that goes to incompetence but
if you do it reasonably well that is you
know if you don't do
try to do as good as we normally can do
with extra money you can actually
achieve this for five billion if we're
if we're totally Optimist you could
probably do it for three but we're being
realistic so five billion dollars you
could do this the other one is on
education okay could I apologize on that
one because I would like to offer the
counters that they might I completely
agree with what you just said
who cares would say Ted Turner yes if
you know they'd rather decrease the
Surplus population right if they'd
rather die they'd better do it decrease
it is it's the the pre-redemption
Ebenezer Scrooge a lot of their policy
proposals in all these agreements
involve depopulation right the
population growth growth problem
um so you're talking about saving lives
I agree I think that's far more
important than you know eliminating a
0.3 degree rise which is probably the
best rate of return if we did everything
they wanted at that uh at that period in
time but that's not a priority if you
look at these International Solutions if
it doesn't equate to stopping the rise
in temperature
hmm I think there you're probably
painting was slightly too broad uh uh
brush a lot of people also in the U.N
actually want to save human lives but
yes there are certainly some people out
there who will say oh but it's not worth
it or you know this is not our primary
uh uh uh uh position and I think you're
absolutely right in the money if you
think global warming is the end of the
world nothing else matters you know if
this is a meteor hurtling towards Earth
we should throw you know drop everything
else we have and just you know get a
hold of Bruce Willis and the guys and
get them up and fix us right uh but but
the truth is it's not a four percent
problem that's why it's so important to
get people to recognize global warming
is not the end of the world it's a
problem just like all the others
unfortunately it's one of those problems
that we unless we do it really smartly
as we talked about with uh research and
development we can spend lots of money
and almost do nothing to solve so why
don't we actually try to solve the
things that we can solve first that
would obviously matter a lot more to
most people on this planet but no and I
I disagree with you a little bit I think
the UN or a lot of these International
you know climate panels because let's be
clear a lot of them exist and they just
kind of all sort of go okay knock it
back to each other
um they want to save lives in relation
to global warming the idea of saving
lives for saving lives sake does it
absolutely does not take the same kind
of Precedence as global warming when we
see this with with grants issued in the
United States for example if I want to
study the uh the the nut Gathering
patterns of the I don't know uh North
Atlantic squirrel nothing I want to
study in relation to global warming
here's a six million dollars yes and so
your solution there for someone who just
wants to save lives absolutely I don't
know how many deaf ears in which it'll
fall if it doesn't tie into reducing
temperature and and that's the issue
that really frankly for me is a is a
moral question as to the soul of what
are what our country wants to do I want
to save those lives um so but let's
let's go to the issue number Stephen
just very very briefly I I hear what you
say and I think there's some of them
where that's actually right but I think
you'd be you'd be you know relieved to
know that there's actually a lot of
people also in even in the UN system who
would also want to just you know care
about human lives and actually care
about tuberculosis malaria and all these
other terrible diseases and also want to
do this and so I think we perhaps even
sort of forgetting that there's people
that we could get on board to say maybe
we should you know spend money more
smartly and more conservatively in the
climate space so that we have some more
money to actually do real good in many
other parts of the world well like
malaria is a good example malaria you
mean things like DDT as opposed to Nets
yeah well we're actually suggesting uh
insecticide treat at nets one of the
reasons is uh DDT uh I'm not saying we
have better options now but I'm saying
back then they said get rid of what
kills them but it's it's really it turns
out that it's really hard unless you're
well organized it's really hard to spray
large areas without screwing it up and
that's one of the corruption things and
incompetence things where insecticide
treated and that's turned out to be a
really cheap way so remember we fix
malaria pretty much everywhere else
except for Africa for two reasons Africa
has the deadliest uh uh variant malaria
at the parasite and then it also has a
mosquito that only uh bites people
whereas the mosquito of the year and I
have bites lots and lots of other
animals and that means it's much easier
to eradicate malaria because it'll
typically not transmit between a lot of
people but in Africa that turns out to
be really hard that's why they're stuck
with this problem it's a poverty related
problem and we know how to do it fairly
easily so again we estimate you know for
about a billion dollars we could save
about 200 000 people each and every year
why don't we be doing that so you know
those are the simple points that we
simply make to say for little money you
can do an amazing radical let me just
tell you one one more thing yeah so so
education obviously everybody agrees is
incredibly important there's a lot of
ways to spend money on education and
deliver very little good uh so you know
Indonesia for instance in the early
2000s uh they decided they were going to
spend a lot more money on education
which is a nice thing uh they ended up
buying a lot more teachers and doubling
uh the wage of teachers so they actually
have one of the lowest class ratios in
the world
they did it in such a way that you could
actually study it and uh scientifically
and there's a very famous article out
there that's called double for nothing
and it basically shows that they doubled
the teachers pay and there was
absolutely no impact on learning now the
teachers were happier not surprisingly
but nice uh but presumably not the main
thing we want out of an educational
system right so the point here is it's
very easy to you know build more schools
feel more like oh we want to give
teachers more pay and then say this is
the good that we do it's both very
costly and it often delivers very little
or possibly even nothing there is a
really really smart way to do something
and that's one that we're advocating
namely if you look at a standard class
everywhere in the world all the 12 year
olds are in the same grade all the 13
year olds in the same grade but
especially in poor countries if you have
these you know 50 12 year old kids in in
one grade they're vastly different some
of these kids are way ahead of the
teacher and many of them have no clue
what's going on what is the teacher
going to do in principle or best that
teachers should should teach each one of
those kids at his or her own level but
you know you can't do that what you can
do and we tested this around the world
you can put this kid one hour a day in
front of a tablet with educational
software that software will very quickly
find out exactly where the student is
and then teach him or her at that exact
level
it means that if you do that so you have
the seven boring hours of school that
doesn't quite work and then you have one
hour where you sit in front of the
tablet it's important because then you
can share the tablet with lots and lots
of other kids if you do that it'll cost
twenty one dollars per kit per year to
do this
for the kid it will mean that they will
learn three years of schooling for every
one year they go to school that's a
fantastic thing because when they then
come go out and become adults and go
into the labor force Market they will be
much more productive and that means they
will be richer their entire nation will
be rich so we estimate for about 10
billion dollars a year we could make
sure that almost everyone in the poor
part of the world so that's almost half
a billion kids in primary school could
be better smarter and make more money
that's worth more than 600 billion
dollars each and every year I who's we
when you say we spend this money because
I'll tell you this we haven't done that
yet we've done the exact same thing in
the United States double for nothing
just to be clear and by the way you can
go back to the early 2000s where we
compared um the private Catholic schools
may not be Catholic you may not like it
you may not like religion some people
out there I don't care they had the
largest classroom sizes per teacher and
they had the best outcomes in New York
City right this idea that oh if there
are more students right but the issue
there is if we get more teachers we pay
them more and have smaller classroom
sizes regardless of performance metrics
uh that's the right thing to do and so
in the United States we've done that and
schools are bloated very expensive the
performance metrics are not any better
yet you still have an entire contingency
of people here against School vouchers
which still means government funded it's
just attached to the student so my
question is if in the United States we
can't get people on board with school
vouchers who's we spending this money in
respectfully
so how do we think Indonesia has a shot
yes yes so we we actually so my
organization we're a small Think Tank
we're like 10 people uh we work with a
lot of the different people this is some
of the smartest economists but also a
lot of governments around the world and
we try to get them to buy into these
ideas because we show them this is what
a lot of really smart people have done a
lot of research have shown really work
so for instance in Malawi we worked with
the malawian government it's one of the
poorest countries in the world in uh
Southeast uh Africa right we actually
showed them that if you spend money on
getting tablets again you need to make
sure that they're well established that
you have the electricity that you have a
place to lock them down and all that
stuff right and some of them are going
to get stolen some are going to be used
and all that stuff
but even if you've taken all that into
account you can actually deliver for
every dollar spent they use quachus area
but for every dollar spent you will
deliver 121 of social good if you do
this they've now decided we're going to
do not just because of what we said but
also because of what we said they're now
going to make sure that they roll it out
to all of Malawi's uh primary school
kids we're simply making the same
argument this is very likely a very good
idea for everyone else in the world and
we as a community as a globe you know
the usaid at Ceta here I'm in Sweden or
Danita whatever it's called but it's
also rich people like Bill Gates and
everybody else but it's also poor
country governments like Malawi and
everywhere else they should spend you
know just a tiny fraction of their money
on doing this because it's one of the
best investments you can do again not
everybody's going to do it and you've
just made the case in in the U.S it's
sometimes hard to get people to do the
SMART stuff but you know if you lay out
a buffet of 12 Amazing Ideas like you
know as we talked about maternal and
newborn Health with malaria with
education and we look at tuberculosis
and land tenure and all these other
things if you do that hopefully some
governments will actually take up some
of these ideas and we estimate they'll
do it so so not amazingly but it'll
still because it's some of the best
things you can do in the world it'll
actually do amazing good for the world
for every dollar spent right well I
certainly agree with the premise by the
way that as opposed to for example
trying to move us to wind and solar to
focus if you're going to be spending the
money on education on basic things like
basic health care Necessities
um I would I agree with all that you
just can color when I said the United
States I mean how much we we have far uh
more overall National spending right on
education in the military it's a common
myth a lot of people don't know that a
lot of it comes from States because of
the way our system works
um we've improved zero so that's where I
go if we can't improve at all on
standardized testing course as a matter
of fact certain communities have gotten
worse in the last uh 15 years with
literacy rates and graduation rates it's
just I I I'm always very apprehensive as
far as Government being capable of being
part of the solution but that doesn't
mean that hey you know it's it's the
lesser of two evils if they're going to
be spending that money
um and I think people like right now
and Stephen again my point is if we're
trying to convince there's about 200
governments in the world right uh and
and you know in some sense you could say
there are 50 in the U.S right if if you
try to tell them here is a great idea
chances are a lot of them are not going
to do it they're going to say no to
vouchers no to there's no to that we're
not going to have you know tablets we're
not going to do all of that yeah shame
you know hopefully you'll do some other
smart stuff but some of them are going
to say yes and that's the whole point uh
I would love to get everyone in the
world to do all the smart stuff I I'm
I'm old enough to know that that's not
going to happen so we have a saying in
our own uh you know sort of organization
it's not about getting everything right
it's a
slightly less wrong right uh if we can
just get there I'd be immensely happy no
and I and and I do appreciate that and I
hope that we can I actually wanted to um
read a quote of yours because this kind
of brings us back to that idea and by
the way a quick question why 12 you is
it I know I know you're friends with
obviously doc Jordan Peterson friend of
mine everyone's doing 12 12 rules for
life is it did I miss that was there a
memo I did baker's dozen
yes well uh so we actually set the
target at it had to be so we do benefit
cost analysis so we simply said it had
to be a big thing so it had to be a big
investment and it had to deliver at
least 15 back in the dollar our overall
outcome in the whole book so the whole
book goes through all of these uh you
know 12 Investments uh it shows that you
can spend about 35 billion dollars and
it'll deliver 4.2 Million Lives so
you'll save to 4.2 Million Lives each
and every year and you'll deliver 1.1
trillion dollars in benefits that's just
fantastic but we just said we're going
to look for all the things that are
above 15 and it turned out that there
were 12. uh I you know it could have
been 13 it could have been 11. it could
have been I don't know uh we've done
this before and we were sort of
expecting a b16. 12 just turns out to be
a nice number but it was not what we
picked it well I thought maybe you guys
you know it was it was the old work of
big now we don't want to hear it it's
the corrupt Invisible Hand of big 12. at
work
um yeah they work with coincide with
Sesame Street you did write this and I
think I said SBG before
um and it's our ESG and E uh sorry it's
s these sdgs for people who aren't aware
of them and you wrote this this quote
you said ambassadors quietly explained
to me that their job wasn't really to
find the best policy Investments for the
world they were there to highlight their
government's particular policy Focus
which was often ideas that played well
at home regardless of how efficient or
not they were at solving Global uh
problems so if if that's true what
actual use are these ambassadors and
their sdgs and explained to people who
sometimes were too close to force to see
the trees what the sdg or these things
are yes so so back in 2015 uh all the
countries in the world got together and
said we want to set a nice sounding uh
things for the world you know promises
that we're going to do for 2030. and
that's what's the sustainable
development goals are they were
eventually put into place and I don't
think anyone really organized it this
way but it ended up being about 80 U.N
ambassadors in New York that did this uh
and and you know the you would like to
believe that they had you know put a an
enormous amount of effort into really
making sure that these were the very
best things to promise for the world uh
but the reality as you also just quoted
was you know the Norwegian Ambassador
came with four things that Norway really
wanted and the Brazilian Ambassador came
with five things that Brazil really
wanted and you know they just ended up
sort of merging all of it and putting it
together into this gigantic package of
we're going to promise everything to
everyone uh and you know it made
everyone feel very good about themselves
and and it had that Kumbaya moment
but the problem of course is promising
everything to everyone means you have no
priorities whatsoever uh and and that's
why we're basically spending lots of
resources and achieving almost nothing
so what I'm trying to say is look it's
beautiful that the world actually wants
to do something good for the world
but maybe instead of just promising
stuff maybe we should start thinking
about what should we be doing and here
are 12 amazing things we could be doing
they're very cheap they'll deliver
amazing benefits maybe we should do
those things first I no I completely
agree with you but you just said these
were 80 ambassadors uh in New York yes
okay so 80 ambassadors let's say they
each averaged four
uh
so and you said you'd like to think it
was very organized now see I understand
and Vern I like you're very diplomatic
but if these numbers and this actually
happened does the word useless mean
anything to you that's what Springs to
mind for me really that's that's where I
go oh so it came it came out let me just
explain explain this very quickly back
in two so the UN has made lots and lots
of promises honestly the world's made a
lot a lot of promises here if you
remember the League of Nations back in
the 1920s they were organized to avoid
war again right after World War one and
of course it
concluded by World War II uh so so we've
made all these promises most of them
have never work but back in 2000 Kofi
Annan who's then Secretary General of
the UN and five other guys and they were
all guys in a back room in the UN made
what was known as the Millennium
development goals and it was a very
short sharp uh uh uh sort of list of
promises you know half the number of
people in poverty half the number of
people in hunger that get kids in school
uh get clean drinking water and
sanitation stopped mom from dying stop
kids from dying that was it
and it actually kind of worked it didn't
work all the way and all that stuff no
honestly but it actually really did a
lot of good so in 1990 about six oh
sorry about 12 million kids died each
and every year uh below the age of five
12 million kids so today that number is
that in 2015 it was down to just 6
million of course that's still way too
many but it was much much fewer and a
large part of this so two or three
million kids are safe because of these
Millennium development goals so they
were really good so we can do something
good if we really prioritize and focus
ourselves but what of course everybody
felt really bad about was this was you
know there's something wrong about six
guys in the back room in the U.N
deciding what the world should do the
next 15 years right so they said we
shouldn't do that we should ask everyone
and that's where the 80 ambassadors and
everybody else came in from so I I think
it was sort of it was natural
understandable mistake but it was a
mistake because no you can't do it that
way you actually have to I don't know
you know do a little analysis yeah we
have a strong leadership yeah you can't
you can't always be run by a vote and
people just want to vote what they want
and then you end up with a wish list but
exactly let me ask you this as someone
who obviously is very and by the way I
hope is as convincing
this is what it comes down to if I sound
negative I hope you're as convincing to
these 80 ambassadors right and these as
you are to the person watching right now
and sometimes having spent time with a
lot of these folks in government I
understand that uh that their Ambitions
are different but let's say that a
viewer right now has a friend or a
spouse family member who and this wee
experience in the United States I don't
know what it's like in Denmark but
you're vilified right they will disagree
with them but also vilify them on the
idea of these these imminent
catastrophic dangers of fossil fuel use
and that we have to move to renewable or
this uh you know the uh the Paris I
always get code protocol Paris Accord uh
otherwise you don't care about the
environment what would you say is the
most compelling evidence or case that
someone right now could could make offer
that person to help them at least see
the point of view of someone like
yourself or myself
the short answer is to ask them to think
what would most people outside of the
rich World say so you know clearly this
one one and a half billion people who
well off you or I am probably most
viewers here uh are are so comfortable
that we can worry about the temperature
in 100 years and look there's a good
reason to say we're a smart Advanced
civilization we can walk into a gum at
the same time we can also be concerned
about that but there's something wrong
about being so concerned about this that
we forget that right now this year
now 2.3 million women and kids are going
to die in childbirth 1.4 million people
are going to die from tuberculosis you
know uh 600 000 are going to die from
malaria and so on and on and on
fundamentally there's a huge amount of
misery and depression depressing stuff
in the world that's happening right now
people who don't have enough food who
don't have enough opportunity who are
left in poverty and hence of course also
much more vulnerable to all these things
that you also worry about you know not
just uh hurricanes that may be caused by
global iron in the future but also all
the Hurricanes that are here right now
so the fundamental point is to say to
these people if you are one of those
6.57 billion people in the world the
vast majority of the world what do you
think you would want us to focus on it's
not first climate change they also want
this to you know focus a little bit on
that but they want to save their kids
from Easley coupon infectious disease
get them out of poverty get them better
education make sure they're not starving
these are very basic things and the
amazing thing is we can solve many of
these problems at very low cost so what
is it do you want to do something
that'll do a little good in 100 years
for you know trillions of dollars or do
you want to do a lot of good right now
for billions of dollars oh and that will
also make the world a lot better place
because if you're richer better educated
you don't die right now it also means
you'll be much more resilient much
better off in 2100.
I think it's a very convincing case it's
uh it's one that uh you know I've seen
uh made for a while but uh I don't think
as effectively with the you know data
driven you know the the access to some
of the data now and you've had with your
Think Tank to compile it so the book is
best things first before my final
question it is uh the 12 most efficient
Solutions this is a long time I know
it's not the title but it's in the it's
you know I got to read solutions for the
world's poorest and our Global sdg
promises that is a mouthful but I want
to make sure I get it right every time
so I do have to read that I don't you
know I have to go to my iPad for that
let me ask you this
um I'm sure a lot of people especially
in the United States will be curious on
this uh as it relates to sort of your
policy proposals right or um
interventions whatever we want to call
them uh ideas how would they be impacted
by let's say a second Biden uh term uh
considering you know that he re he
signed back on to um the Paris Accord uh
and then I would ask what what it would
look like with for example since we've
had both of them a second Donald Trump
term
yeah so so again my senses
political divide that very obviously is
there on on the climate discussion I
think very clearly uh Biden
Administration would think a lot less of
my advice on climate than perhaps a
trumpet but why would they though you're
a scientist and I mean that why would
they think less of it why this why do
they dismiss fully qualify
because at the end of the day a lot of
this and this is not just from Biden
this is also from Trump right you're
looking for the stuff that you want to
hear uh so yeah uh I I think you know
that that's just a matter of fact from
of the world but I actually think both
administrations would like
to be the ones who made sure that you
got better education that you got moms
to stop dying in childbirth that you got
better in nutrition that you got all
these other very very obvious things and
so I think there's a real Beauty to you
know the book and the message uh it's
not just that this is fantastically
effective way to spend money but it's
also something that Democrats and
Republicans can kind of get together on
you know spending a little money
incredibly effectively to do good in the
world most people actually like that
idea and and so yes there is going to be
some friction from both sides probably
but I think this is something that you
could bring people together on that you
know in this hyper partisan world is
actually something to be slightly
celebrated I actually you know in the
way you describe third um but I would be
somewhat optimistic because all all
unfortunately all American presidents
love to spend our money uh but if you're
going to spend it spend on things that
are appropriate here's what I would
would and spend a little rather than a
lot right that's what I was going to say
yes with uh let's say it's it's uh
President Biden if you get in a room
with them right the pitch needs to be
that this would do a lot more good right
as it relates to overall kind of climate
impact and human suffering that would be
important and you could add to that if
you're dealing with uh president uh
let's say Trump or it could be if it's
Republican is actually we could spend
less and be more effective
these different these different sort of
messages might resonate more effectively
with either one and I may have spent
significant amount of time with certain
people so I'm telling you what I
hopefully would like to see pitched
because I do think that a lot of your
ideas would be very productive and I
appreciate you you know it's often a
thankless effort so uh thank you for
doing it and uh I hope other people
listen and Stephen just just on the on
the last bit that's exactly why I call
it best things first you know it's it's
in in a sort of way to say look I know
that you want to do a lot of other
things you know a sort of a right-wing
Administration will give more money back
to the uh to the taxpayers and their
left-wing government will will spend
more money but at least do this first
right do the smartest the best things
first yes that we could possibly agree
on well I'm saying yeah you would think
so but what I'm saying is best things
first in the in America Democrats don't
care like yeah sure another trillion
dollars it doesn't matter so I'm saying
I wouldn't lead with that whereas I know
someone going all right what's our
budget
um you know that's something and I
completely agree with you look I think
everything is about a risk reward right
and again the dollar metrics we're using
for people I know they're going to be in
the comments section we're not actually
just talking about in a dollar return
we're talking about in a a social return
an environmental return as well as yeah
uh an economic return and by the way for
people who are watching if uh you like
if you want to go and read his book hit
like below comment show him you love
them uh I do understand that look people
who work Behind These the the scenes on
these things are the movers and shakers
and it often uh may not be credited uh
as much as well today in the air of
podcasts that's changed but I hope
people are listening and uh I'd love to
have you back sometime when you write
your next book 12 more efficient
Solutions
oh yes that's what I have to do now yeah
I got the memo you did get the memo you
gotta stay with 12. Bjorn thank you so
much brother I appreciate it and uh I'll
talk to you again
[Music]
foreign